all right we have gotten to the end to
some degree of the Trump defamation and
rape trial brought by E Gene Carroll we
now have video of Trump's deposition it
is as crazy as anything I have ever seen
here is a unbelievable moment I would
dare say kafka-esque Trump has long held
one of the reasons he would not have
sexually assaulted e Gene Carroll is not
that he doesn't sexually assault women
it's that she's not his type
that's about physical attraction
in this video I'm about to play for you
this is unbelievable Trump is given a
picture of e Gene Carroll and he
believes that it's his ex-wife Marla
Maples someone he presumably was
attracted to
completely destroying the notion that e
Gene Carroll is not someone that is
Trump's type he thought it was his own
ex-wife take a look at this I don't even
know who the woman let's say I don't
know who it's Marla
okay it's Marla means it's my ex-wife
Marla Maples
there's like marbles in this photo
that's Marla yeah that's that's my wife
which one woman are you pointing each
other now here
oh the person you just pointed to
was oh
and the person the woman on the right is
your then wife I don't know this was the
picture I assume that's John Johnson is
that because it's very blurry there you
go
Trump insists
but and again I I'm ski I'm not focusing
on the insanity of being accused of
having sexually assaulting someone and
then saying they're not my type
the right reaction from someone who
doesn't commit sexual assault would be
I've never sexually assaulted anyone and
I I don't sexually assault people anyway
it's not his type except it sort of
seems like she was because he thought it
was his own ex-wife that is wild wild
stuff and somehow the people defending
Biden were supposed to believe are
creepy in some way uh we then get to the
next
um section about this about she's not my
type it wouldn't be my first choice and
Trump I think in this clip he also tells
the lawyer asking him the questions that
she wouldn't be a Top Choice for Trump
either
look at this when you said in that video
that misleads would not be your first
choice
you were referring to her physical looks
correct just the overall not I I look at
her I see her I hear what she says
whatever you wouldn't be a choice of
mine either to be honest with you I hope
you're not insulted wow I would not
under any circumstances have any
interest in you
I'm being I'm honest when I say it she I
would not have any interest in when you
grotesque stuff
grotesque stuff Trump wouldn't be
interested in misleads or E Gene Carroll
or the lawyer asking the question he's
just not interested the good news per
Trump is if he doesn't find you
attractive he wouldn't sexually assault
you
of course I would be much more inspired
if Trump were to say doesn't matter how
attractive I find someone I would never
commit an act of sexual assault that's
not what he has chosen to say Trump also
challenged
um the timeline of the infamous Access
Hollywood tape where he talks about when
you're famous they just let you do it
you can grab them by the you know what
Trump asked about whether he was engaged
to Melania at different points in time
and whether that would make that video
more or less problematic or whatever
Trump just basically plays Dumb and says
I don't remember when I was married I
don't remember when I was engaged I
don't know am I correctly that video was
recorded in September 2005.
I guess that would I don't know the date
but whatever date it was is fine with me
and am I correct that you were engaged
to your current life sometime in 2004. I
don't know am I correct that you married
your current wife in January 2005. I
don't know relative to that tape yeah
Michael doesn't know when he was married
now he's trying to get out of it by
saying I don't know when the marriage
happened relative to that tape
but I mean listen I'm not married don't
most people remember when they got
married is that a crazy thing to think
you would remember I don't know married
people can write to me and let me know
the topic of the Access Hollywood tape
did come up uh multiple times here's
another moment of that in this video
I just started kissing them it's like a
magnet just kiss I don't even wait
and when you're a star they let you do
it you can do anything grab them by the
you can do anything that's what you said
correct well historically that's true
with stars Trump's a historian here
that's all he meant he just meant
from the point of view of a history buff
when you're famous they just let you do
it you can grab them by the you know
what
true with stars that they can grab women
but well that's what it's if you look
over the last million years
a million years I have to go back with
that over the last million years 250
000 of which it was modern humans and
then before that even in pre-human times
um you could just that when you were a
star pre-human Stars you know 750 000
years ago they would just let you do it
it started to I started thinking to
myself they're talking about stars and
Trump's talking about a million years is
it possible Trump's talking about actual
stars like out in space and this is
actually about something totally
different let's go back uh for the last
million years Trump weighs in on human
history let's listen it's true with
stars that they can grab women but
it's if you look over the last million
years I guess that's been largely true
not always but largely true
unfortunately or fortunately that's
that's an even crazier little bookend
fortunately or unfortunately I guess it
depends on the eye of the beholder who's
doing the grabbing and who's being
grabbed for a million years when you're
a star they just let you do it this guy
is out of his mind truly now just for
contrast here's the one clip of this
nonsense that Fox News played which
quite frankly is like they found the
only 30 seconds where Trump doesn't seem
as grotesque listen
I didn't have to reach out to anybody
because it didn't happen
um and and by the way if it did happen
it would have been reported within
minutes
talking about going to a major floor
probably I assume the most important
floor
uh a major floor in a major department
store that's a very busy store by the
way right and
check out counters and everything else
and I would be in there I mean it's the
most ridiculous it's the most ridiculous
disgusting story it was just made up now
two things one Fox News picking the clip
they skip all the grab them by the you
know what they skipped Trump telling the
lawyer he's not attracted to her which
is crazy
and they picked this one clip where
Trump seems more defiant about just it's
all made up the funny thing is even this
clip isn't that great for Trump if you
understand the full story because Trump
has insisted as part of his defense he
never would really go to that store
Bergdorf Goodman he just he's not super
familiar with it he never went there but
he knows about the crowds and he knows
about which floors are the most
important floors which would have the
biggest crowds even this clip to The
Knowing Observer
contradicts the story Trump has been
telling over and over and over and over
again so the deposition video is Bonkers
cuckoo for Cocoa Puff stuff the both
sides have rested we will see what
ultimately comes of this defamation and
rape trial but if you understand the
back story Trump doesn't exactly look
good here
one of our sponsors is electric e-bikes
I've been watching e-bike reviews on
YouTube for a while because I've been
thinking of getting one and I
continually come across electric as the
brand to go with if your budget is
between 800 and 1300 and I have to agree
from experience I've had my electric
e-bike for a little while now I've
almost ditched my car and regularly bike
at this point for errands and things
around my neighborhood it's awesome
cardio because I'm still pedaling I get
there faster I can see more I'm reducing
my carbon footprint the e-bike came to
my doorstep fully assembled it has a
bright LCD screen seven speed gearing
five levels of pedal assist a powerful
battery that you can take inside to
charge it's also fully foldable I can
put it in the back of my car electric
has models for every lifestyle and you
can Finance for as little as 73 bucks a
month go to electricebikes.com to learn
more explore all of the incredible
e-bike models they offer the link is
down below